So to talk about other tools
that you might use for
prototyping, we've brought
in Cody from Pixate.
>> Hi, there.
>> So Cody, what is Pixate?
>> Pixate is a prototyping
platform definitely used for
more intense animations or
detailed animations, interactions also.
But it's all done natively, so on
the device that you're prototyping for,
you get the same effects on
scroll views, on the animations,
anything that you would normally see in
an app, we can reproduce through Pixate.
>> Perfect, that's wonderful.
So it sounds like it's good at these
sort of higher fidelity prototypes.
It's good at these
micro-interactions and
getting things right when you're
doing some small part of the app.
>> Right, it definitely focuses on
reproducing a real experience within
the app, as opposed to, maybe ones that
are more, you know, like paper for
instance, or
anything like that where it,
you don't get the full feeling of it.
What you can do is, when you prototype
through Pixate, you can basically
hand this over to someone, a developer,
someone maybe you're selling the app to,
and show them exactly how you
expect it to work as the designer.
>> So a tool like Pixate would make
it much easier to have a design
consultation, we'll be doing
later on in the lesson.
So Cody, why are micro-interactions
important for a prototype?
>> Micro-interactions are really
important from the design aspect because
you want to show exactly the animations,
the movement of the different elements
within the app to give everyone a better
idea of what you're trying to build and
what you kind of envision
as the designer.
>> So what kind of questions do you get
from entrepreneurs about your product?
>> A lot of questions
we get are related to
what to do with it once
you've created a prototype.
I feel like that may be kind of
a pain point for some people,
because they hear they have this design
and they can show it to whomever.
However, they get to hand
this over to a developer now,
and show them exactly
the animations they're looking for.
And the developer, for the most part,
can translate that over to code, and
then generate the app from there.
>> Okay, so
once you've built the prototype,
you get a lot of questions
about what to do with it,
and your suggestions are pretty much,
have it built.
>> Mm-hm, that's correct,
yeah, just build it.
Just hand it over to the developer and
build from there.
We want to work on obviously a lot
of ways to improve that process,
like giving in code export or,
you know, other features like that,
which we're kind of working
on alongside other features.
Ultimately, right now the best way
to do it is to just show them.
>> Okay, perfect.
So we've covered what you do once
you've gotten the Pixate prototype.
What is the process for
getting in to the Pixate prototype?
Let's say we've got people who have
an InVision prototype or have a set of
screens that have already been made,
what do they do to get that into Pixate?
>> Ideally, the best way to do it is,
so the way the Pixate works is
it works solely with assets,
assets being images or soon actually
video, and things like that.
What they'll want to do is take that
information or those images they have
through InVision, those screens, and
transfer them into Sketch, Photoshop,
anything like that, and then from that
point they can put it into Pixate,
create them as individual layers and
start playing around with
creating those interactions.
>> Perfect, thank you.
Thank you for coming in Cody.
>> Not a problem at all, thank you.